♪♪♪
- [Scott Cowan:] We're gonna be hitting on top of the Wynn.
- Oh, my goodness.
Why is he smiling? I'm hitting him right in his veneers.
Do you think it's right on his nose?
What's up, Bleacher Report? Bryson DeChambeau here. Here at the Wynn about to go up to one more spot that I heard is pretty cool. Come check it out.
- So we're going to head up to, into the hotel.
- [Bryson DeChambeau:] OK.
- [Cowan:] And up to the 60th floor
- Sixtieth?!
- We're going to do something here that no one has ever done before, and I think you're gonna to be excited and interested in the target
- OK.
- that you're about to hit.
♪♪♪
- [DeChambeau:] Good, how are you doing?
All right, headed up to the 60th floor rooftop.
We'll see you up there.
♪♪♪
- [Cowan:] Bryson, come on out here.
- Alrighty. This is kinda insane. Oh-o-o-o. I would have never thought I'd ever be up here in my entire life. Ooh-oo-oo-oo, I'm ripping some bombs off of here.
Oh, my gosh, how beautiful is this?
Oh, there he is. Why is he smiling? I'm about to hit his face.
All right, what's the yardage?
- [Cowan:] 521 yards.
- [DeChambeau:] Wow.
- [Cowan:] We're gonna have you at about 650 feet.
- [DeChambeau:] What's the slope adjustment down to the target?
- [Cowan:] We have it at 19 degrees with a wind of about nine-and-a-half miles an hour.
- I might hit that Alaska plane right there.
[Laughing]
OK, that's a little, little different than I've ever experienced.
That is f--king gone.
[Laughing]
- [Associate producer:] Little short.
- [Producer:] Little short.
- Oh, you think?
[Hitting golf ball]
All right. This is the real deal. Coming for you, Brooks.
♪♪♪
Ooh, that was hit hard. This is so much fun.
How far short is that?
- [Producer:] How far short was that one?
- [Associate producer:] Fifty yards short to the right
- Fifty?
- [Associate producer:] by the water.
- [DeChambeau:] Just, just wait, guys, I'm getting comfortable still.
Oh. No, just drew a little bit. Come on, ball. That's got a chance. That's got a chance!
- [Associate producer:] Twenty yards short.
- [DeChambeau groaning] I see it. OK.
[Yelling]
Oh, it's so good too. Gosh darn it. Oh. Ooh, was that hit hard.
It's gonna happen. Don't worry.
- [Associate producer:] Short and left of the fairway.
- [DeChambeau:] I know. I know. I see it.
- [Associate producer:] All short.
- OK. Really? Thanks.
​​♪♪♪
Ooh. Do your thing, baby. Do your thing. It's right on his nose.
It's going right for him, come on.
Oh. Oh, my gosh! Oh, my gosh.
- [Associate producer:] Two feet short.
- Two feet.
- [Associate producer:] So close.
- No excuses. We're doing it right here, right now.
♪♪♪
- [Producer:] Shot coming.
- Oh! Stay on the target, baby.
- [Associate producer:] He hit the target!
- Whoo-hoo-oo-oo-oo!
- [Cheering]
-  Let's go, baby! That was sick.
Whoo-hoo I'm gonna hit another one. That was sick.
- [Cheering]
- [DeChambeau laughing] Let's go.
♪♪♪
All right, I just nailed Brooks' big head on top of the Wynn,
500 yards away. Now it's time to go beat his butt in the real Match.
♪♪♪